so time then for the press preview first
look at what is on
the front of saturday's papers uh
tonight we'll see what's making those
headlines with paul mckenzie from the
think tank demos and pr consultant
alex dean a very good evening to both of
you chat in a second first of all let's
take a look at those front pages
for you why don't we start with the
times leading on the warning from
scientists that there could be a
third wave of coronavirus infections as
case numbers
surge across europe here's your
telegraph the former head of the vaccine
task force has accused some european
leaders of being irresponsible
after they cast doubt on the efficacy of
the oxford jab
the star is also critical of europe
stance accusing some leaders of vaccine
nationalism
the sun has a picture of the prime
minister having his jab
as the number of doses given in a day
hits a new record
the yorkshire post reports on the mental
health crisis brought about by the
pandemic and says younger women
are the worst affected the mail says
there are questions to be answered over
some of the costs associated with the
refurbishment of boris johnson's flat
onto the ft the government is said to be
drawing up plans to run liberty steel
with public
money while it looks for a buyer
harry just say sorry to the queen is the
headline in the express
and the mirror reports that brad pitt's
son has testified against his father
in his parents divorce case
and i'm joined by polly mckenzie and
alex dean
hello to you both uh right let's start
with the front of times then
um polly it's a it's a tale of two
stories really
on the one hand we've got boris johnson
thumbs up he's had
his jab we've had this record-breaking
day more than 660 000
jabs first and second doses but then if
you look at the
the other side of the coin alarm over
new wave
um you know we've got these rising
infections on the continent which which
really are
a concern aren't they yeah we've been
doing fantastically on the vaccine roll
out and even though there's been
some concerns over a kind of slight
slowdown in the supplies we're getting
over the coming months this was a record
day and that is just brilliant to see
but partly because vaccine rollout has
been much slower
across most of most of europe they are
seeing this
wave you know tens of thousands of cases
a day in some
countries because they're not
vaccinating their populations quickly
enough and of course lots of those cases
will be among younger people who
we hope will will not die but they are
still huge numbers of vulnerable
older people including you know i
confess and interest
my mum my stepdad both who live in
france
haven't been able to get a vaccination
if they were in the uk that have been
vaccinated more than a month ago
they could just walk up to a clinic now
and get a vaccination they're not even
allowed into the country
so it's incredibly frustrating and it
reminds us that
no country is really free from this
virus
until we all are and lots of those cases
in in continental europe well i mean
it's a small proportion
perhaps five percent are the south
african variant against which the
vaccines are the least effective that
they're still quite effective they're
still better than nothing
and so there is real cause for concern
we absolutely have to do what we can to
encourage support whatever it is these
european nations to
pick up the pace yeah i mean it was the
wh so secretary general i think wasn't
it who said no one is safe
until everyone is safe but alex when you
look at this headline
uh alarm over new wave um you know we
can learn from history here can't we
because
when there was a you know rising cases
in europe then eventually there was a
rise in cases here how concerned are you
that things could start
going the wrong way in britain despite
the success of the vaccine rollout
well the logic you've given is the logic
that our scientists give for being so
concerned that we always seem to follow
behind what's happening
in the european union there seem to be
two significant things
in our favor the first is that our
testing
regime is really good and that's
something that we have
implemented and developed over a
significant period of time sunk a lot of
resource into some people criticize that
i don't
um but you know our testing in schools
has has been very good and so far rates
of infection are very low
and the second thing that we should take
comfort from is that our vaccination
rate is so much
better than elsewhere and if you get
enough of your population up to
being vaccinated in the end it's a great
sign and it's much more likely you can
unlock but in the end of course if we
want to liberalize and have travel again
and be able to
have normal life back the way that we
used to then we desperately need our
european friends to get their house in
order as well
and the frustrating thing for those
people who are overseeing these programs
is that on the one hand it's been very
centralized by european authorities in
procurement terms but also in kind of
authority and agency terms and but the
ema on the other hand
has been consistent saying astrazeneca
oxford jab is fine
and then the nation states which cleaved
more or less uh to the
behavior of the european union in
procurement terms then
go their own way and completely ignore
the advice uh
on the job so i mean people in europe
must be
holding their head in their hands and
wishing that they had a program like
ours at the moment
yeah i mean it's the theme uh that the
daily telegraph
uh reports on on the front page europe's
stance on oxford jab
irresponsible says vaccine tsar they've
got
an interview with with kate bingham and
polly
uh it has put things back a lot hasn't
it this uh concern
uh in europe over the oxford astrazeneca
jab because we know many countries like
france for example
they're already vaccine hesitant and
this is just going to make things even
worse
in a way the worse your vaccine
hesitancy problem
is to start with the more cautious you
need to both be and see
be seen to be to build confidence that
you're not just being cavalier about
a new medicine on the other hand when
you act like this when you
pull a vaccination program you pause it
you go forward
you know unfortunately what it does for
some people is reinforce that
that vaccine hesitancy you know on the
one hand it's of course really important
that nation states have the freedom
to make their own choices to follow the
needs of their population and to make
their own judgments
and that is an important part of
building up people's confidence
nevertheless it seems to me that this
precautionary principle the idea that
you
don't do something new unless you're
certain that it can be safe
instead of weighing in the balance the
harm of doing nothing
against the possible risks of doing
something
is in the end as kate bingham says just
a mistake and i am certainly glad that
our regulatory agency does have a more
um risk risk welcoming approach actually
to say that you balance the risks of the
new thing against the risks of doing
nothing
and that is one of the reasons why why
we are ahead on this and i do hope
that we will now see a shift in their
perspective
because it's really clear you know that
just the numbers i'm not a statistician
but you know
you you can see so many examples of
really clever people
running the numbers through the model
whatever these possible risks and
they seem so microscopic but if you
weigh them against the number of lives
you will save by
getting those vaccinations into people's
arms
it's just it frankly it's it's just not
really a question
yeah alex the uh the daily star isn't
holding back wanted
uh they've got a wanted poster on their
front page uh for four years we thought
donald trump was deranged but these euro
herberts
are running him a very close second over
the oxford vaccine i mean there is a
danger isn't there that front pages like
this aren't
hugely helpful um we're already seeing
vaccine nationalism
uh we're also seeing a bit of jingoism
as well um i mean the thing is this is a
global effort isn't it
well i don't say most of us aren't
taking our steer from
the star in the political stance that
we'll take mildly amusing front page
um but i of course wasn't saying that
nation states shouldn't have
the ability to control their fates in
fact i think rather more they should
i think they just got it wrong is the
point on the astrazeneca
uh oxford vaccine i mean macaron is a
case in point of course his position has
gone from saying
that they wouldn't have the astrogenic
vaccine that his efficacy was unproven
to saying we're not going to use it but
you can't have it to the uk
the uh macron and the manger syndrome uh
through to
okay then we will use it to we're not
going to use it again but we still won't
export it to
we are going to use it but now only for
the elderly that we said it wouldn't
work with before
i mean a total mishmash but of course
he's got vandalian there making him look
good
so there is a certain amount of um
sympathy we can have with our european
friends but i thought that patrick flynn
put it very well
in one of the newspapers telegraph i
think um
today about the extent to which we can't
be you know no one takes pleasure in
another country doing badly because
until this gets fixed we
trade isn't going to get back to where
it ought to be we're not going to be
able to have holidays that we might wish
to have
jobs aren't going to be on the rebound
in the way that we want
so to the point that you were both
making before yes until everyone's okay
we're going to struggle a bit but let's
be clear we are ahead of the game now in
the united kingdom and we
should be proud of that after all if the
uk was behind
eu nations i have no doubt that our
media will be bashing the hell out of
our government
just let's just give credit we're
credited to just staying with you very
briefly i mean do you think our
government
can be criticized for for behaving
differently towards the eu
as it is towards india for example it's
very careful not to criticize india
although um it's been accused of holding
back doses
uh whilst accusing the eu of um talking
about potentially doing the same thing
and being very understanding i'll notice
the contractual position is different my
understanding on that is that
um in the indian example the contract
the contract
obliges uh the provider to give vaccines
at some point but doesn't give the uk
first preference
in fact that facility does have explicit
first preference for
india and when you bear in mind the size
of the indian population what one can
imagine that's going to be some time
whereas the vaccines that we're talking
about from
eu based factories not eu vaccines but
back
factories in the eu producing the
bacteria the vaccines
the contracts there does give the uk
first preference because we got in early
and we procure faster
than other people so it's qualitatively
different
so the comparison's a bit misleading
okay all right well let's finish uh this
part polly with the front of the
yorkshire post another depressing
headline i'm afraid mental health crisis
soaring
in the pandemic this is a warning for
employers
um uh really highlighting just how
difficult the last year's been
yeah and for different groups of people
very different
but for some people it's been incredibly
stressful because they've been lonely
for some people it's been incredibly
stressful because they've been unable to
get away from caring responsibilities
uh family whatever that might be some
people have lost their jobs some people
have lost their livelihoods
some people have had the enormous
pressure of of
you know frontline jobs putting
themselves uh at risk so
across the board there is this huge
mental health impact
one of the things that i think employers
can do is think about people's financial
health
actually the the more financial problems
which so many of us are going to have as
a result of this crisis
are both a cause and a consequence of
mental health problems
and because employers are you know the
control of people's pay packets
they can do a huge amount about
supporting people to help manage their
money
maybe access credit through their
employer through their payroll
to help people kind of recover from what
for so many people will be a huge kind
of debt and mental health hangover
yeah quick thought on this from you alex
yeah well some great friend
pages today right now telegraph hat tip
for the kate big and exclusive interview
yorkshire post great front page about
the importance of mental health in this
crisis
just one of the reasons we've got to
come out of lockdown my final thought on
that would be
the health select committee health and
social care select committee
house of commons is having an
investigation into the impact on
children
of mental health um from coronavirus and
and lockdown
and i think that's the flip side of what
the yorkshire post is covering so well
today
it's not just affecting one group in
society lockdown has a terrible effect
on many many groups in our society and
that's one of the reasons we've just got
to get out of it as soon as we can
yeah many kids um actually struggling
with return to school interestingly
um alex and polly thank you both very
much speak again in a couple of minutes
uh coming up
it's a photograph on all the papers
front pages the prime minister
getting his vaccine bow jab is the sun's
headline discussing that in a couple
months
welcome back uh polly and alex still
with me uh alex let's turn to the front
page of the
sun it's a photo on all the front pages
uh boris johnson
getting his jab uh he must be very aware
mustn't he that he is now part of the
last
group of people to get their first job
certainly for the next few weeks
yeah it's a really important image and i
think that um
seeing that people have trust in this
is something that resonates around the
world this is the reason we see people
taking these photographs it's why to
return to the thing we're discussing in
the first half president macron said he
would take the astrazeneca vaccine if he
was offered it that was a really kind of
important message
to the people of france that's why we've
seen politicians rolling up their sleeve
literally
to have the jab and i thought james
cleverley today was the latest
example of someone of black minority
ethnic background
making a point of encouraging others to
get vaccinated and not to harbor
concerns about getting vaccinated
because these things matter
symbols matter our prime minister having
the vaccine
that is important as a statement in the
country i'm really glad that it's
happened
yeah and uh polly the prime minister the
french prime minister also getting uh
a jab in fact quite quite a few leaders
have been photographed getting their
jabs uh in the last 24 hours or so
yeah and as alex says that's incredibly
important for sending the message of
confidence
that other people should be absolutely
accepting those appointments if they if
they are offered them
as soon as as soon as they're offered
them i i must alert those viewers there
is one
lord bethel who is a health minister jim
bethel who decided to take his entire
shirt off
for his vaccinations so definitely avoid
that photograph if you
if you care yes uh boris johnson did
manage
to avoid that when he had his jab a
little bit earlier on and let's finish
uh alex with this story i mean what is
going on here
a whiskey flavored kitkat
japanese market has always proven to be
of interest for
products which we might think of as
esoteric in
um british tastes a whiskey flavour
kitkat actually is not one of them
i think i'd really like this i think
this is a product that is being limited
uh by just being given to the japanese
market i'm very glad that they
have featured it in fact the japanese
have hundreds of varieties of kitkats i
happen to
remember so in the end they were always
going to get to the whiskey one i
say let's bring it home it's time for
the whiskey kitkat to be released in the
uk
polly you were holding your nose i mean
does this not uh suit you
well i'm so glad that finally we found
something that alex and i can profoundly
disagree
just no there's just no no no before
christmas they released a a gin and
tonic flavored after eight which
honestly was the worst substance
known to matter you have to get in one
hand the after eight in the other
have the whiskey in one hand the kit-kat
in the other they do not need
no i think i think i'm with you um have
a break have a kit kat
we're gonna have a break now uh thank
you both very much indeed we'll see you
in half an hour
or so